there what the hell game time let's go
and there we go they've started and
they've started guys thank you so much
redness and ryan
and goblin to nebray with the five and
just continuing jesse werner with the
five
holy small oh my god oh my god checkers
be with 25
holy smokes what is this
this is biblical biblical levels there's
no
this is the great flood right here holy
smokes checkers b
thank you so much
oh yeah b6 arraigned yeah you played
this one
this week charlie should just go knight
f6 or e6 oh my god kelly from sales put
the bishop here
holy smokes yeah
oh he played b3 yeah so i think i have
to go oh my god
and sign kim or do i just push this and
then the knight first
maybe i'm over complicating it maybe i
push this the night instead of
oh my god i think that's probably it
or even better i could play them
ridiculous i just get a free pawn just
go knight f6
i think we talked about this briefly
nice it's gonna fall i'm down to get
wacky
uh i already charlie stepping it up here
knight of six is a great move
thank you a williams the prime 50 subs
from ensland kim
we're over 6k oh my god
we're well over 6k okay guys this is
crazy so i just saw the [ __ ]
thank you so much everybody is amazing
amazing oh my
okay okay another 50.
holy smokes this might be the most epic
sub run i have ever seen hojo jordan
with another 50. what is this
6100 i can't even take and win it back
because you didn't i am literally yeah
e59d5 is fine
this is incredible guys thank you so
much sick sick stuff going on here
okay charlie's game already heating up
the good thing is this no he goes back
to g8 okay so he's gonna
that's not a great move by charlie i'm
surprised he did that
jay cardinals thanks for the prime he's
got to go d6 right
now knight g8 was a really weird move to
this pressure i don't get it i mean
oh leia origami thanks for the fun
knight d5 is uh
what we talked about charlie
confusing something here yeah he's he's
kind of in his head already
no this is not a disaster you can go d6
here nope there's two attackers on it
his night got trapped see the problem
with what he does is he he gets scared
because something happened in another
game and he completely psyched himself
out but d6 is a great move no he's fine
here the real mr ferrick with ten holy
smokes it just keeps going
what are you guys doing this is crazy
oh my god amazing amazing vibes here as
charlie playing the right move that was
a very important we need to get rid of
this pawn
so that the knight can get back to f6
and then he can actually develop
overseas
before pushing this so you guys can see
like he understands these positions a
lot better than i used to [ __ ] up
i should have played this both of them
burning into their clock
thank you so much real mr perry i'm oh
my gosh
it's fine lillian bernstein
holy smokes okay d4 is weird
so i think charlie can just take this
thing charlie can just take this thing i
don't get that move at all
mormon bishop thank you friend i haven't
developed do i want to do a queen
oh my god thunderous prime 1511 it just
continues
come on charlie take the pawn take the
pawn charlie and
i don't know what rayne wants because if
knight takes he just loses the pun now
charlie is underdeveloped here but it's
fine he's solid
take the punch charlie there's nothing
to think about here
now i don't want him to take this pawn
because then rain could advance his
spawn to d5 and attack the knight
and this gets a little bit no mere man
okay so he takes d4 and thank you
retinas c takes d4
as a line sonnenberg thank you i think i
take down here
yeah cd is good for black aquila gifting
to alexa vdv thank you
i i don't get what he's thinking about
here he's already psyching himself out
yeah come on charlie take on e4 i'm not
i'm not in a [ __ ] position like this
automatically i have this check but it's
not really good
yeah uh like i i don't
he just blocks it with his knight maybe
no but cd black is just better here
or you could even just push this pawn
black is better
and range is blundered pawn this is a
senseless move
maybe i just deliver the check anyway
this is like an automatic response
i'm worried he's going to do something
like this or he's going to do this
i'm doing it i'm worried no it's a dumb
check which is it's like violates all
the rules
talks about it a million times get your
pieces out take
i'm doing it yeah that's that's not a
horrible move that's just a minute
this is mine in these i'm just gonna
play faster now
now it's not terrible i mean bishop
it's not horrible i guess it it forces
rain to decide what he's walking with
fancy candy
with the tier one thank you
we somehow need to find a way going for
it okay now definitely what about
just when's the pawn here this knight is
pinned how how did it also gets rid of
this
yeah it takes and just 95 or what
queenie five
and he's fine bishop he's i mean he's
underdeveloped here but he's fine
he takes i think it's just a free pun
this is literally there we go my boy
there we go now he's got to speed up a
little bit here
tequila gifting to tave thank you
i have never seen anything like this
okay knight takes e5 come on charlie
just take that damn pawn of the night
now queenie five-track is not the best i
know he thinks that he thinks
it's a fork he plays
okay i guess takes you on he wants to do
this
wait but why not start developing again
but [ __ ] incredible he is fine here
as long as he develops his pieces he's
actually completely fine
bc charlie is better here i mean black
is
well he's not no he's worse he's the
worst brain though i don't think
he's gonna go boys chuckle chuck brain
has to go here
but if he can get his king excited he'll
end up being better so according to the
computer black is worse but
you can you can draw it up here to
punish
this develop bishop try just [ __ ]
desperately try and count
i think reigns going to go bishop c4
that would be my guess
charlie has to get the but don't go i'm
afraid he's gonna go g6
okay so now both of them about equal on
the clock
do i have something better maybe no
do i right i unders oh my god he does it
bishop d7 now
and if char if rain castles then this is
hanging
yeah man charlie's facing beasts to
start a bishop d7 charlie come on bishop
d7 knight f6 he's still fine
bishop d7 castle's knight f6 charcoal
chocolate thanks for the prime
shift d7 castle's knight of six charlie
defend the pawn please
do i have a wave defend the pawn please
detecting this with tempo i don't think
so
queen of three is not an easy move what
no no there's no way he misses this one
what else is he attacking
there's no way mr seven i can't do
anything about that right now knight is
still pinned he'll castle here but uh
yeah okay bishop that's not a great move
though he's see he's missing the point
because oh my
range is knight f6 though knight f6 and
e6
reign is incredibly underrated obviously
he's i think he's 14 1500
in full strength knight f6 charlie
develop your damn pieces come on
develop your pieces
i mean e6 is okay here but attacking
right now it should not take any time
here and
i don't know i can't tell you guys how
many times we've spoken about this when
you're in a situation like this you
develop your pieces
and um there's nothing to think about
here knight f6
i can just tell he's freaking out
yeah he's got a castle but even more
important than castling is to get his
pieces out and black is fine here i mean
there's nothing really to worry about
knight f6 charlie come on
he needs that we need to get him a
sports psychologist
i mean
that is a thing i actually worked with
one
i don't think there's anything he'd do
for a little stretch
this knight doesn't have any good safe
squares
no it's not a it's not a uh like a a
crazy thing at all
chess is an incredibly stressful game i
i understand why
he gets nervous but anything out of it
yet you know
okay so e6 again i don't get why he
wouldn't bring his knight out first e6
is not terrible though at least he gets
his pieces out
gives him gives his pieces a little bit
of now what would rain knight e4 is a
super strong move here from right well
that would maybe drop this final though
charlie is playing with a lot of fire
here
why is bishop d7 better than bishop b7
well the bottom line is
bishop on d7 sort of protects more of
the central space
now charlie has to get his night out
move immediately charlie come on
knight f6 there's see here this is
exactly he should spend 10 seconds
identify the threat
no thread knight f6 come on charlie
bring your knight out
bishop b5 was fine but but this is just
he's just he's shooting himself in the
foot that's looking at
well there's no free pawn though because
like this is defended attacking this
is it trying to trap me because that
won't work either i have plenty of
escapes
this is what's this is what's so tilting
to watch folks
bishop a3 is okay bishop a3 is
definitely a good move
i would just go knight f6 but it's the
same thing that happens
every single game look at the clock
thank you ball okay so he's got bishop
a3
the problem with this move at a high
level is that why can go knight to e4
here and if you guys look at this
position that bishop
was guarding the d6 square so rain could
get his knight into d6 this would be
devastating
finding that would not be easy so that's
why charlie
i told him nights before bishops always
tell them the same thing nights before
bishops usually
um but it kind of goes out the window
here everything goes out the window
do i think this is a good move [ __ ] no
rain will not play 10 out of 10 times
but he might find it
i mean rain might find it i won't be
surprised he's he's really strong
knight b5 will not probably not there is
no way
i mean i think gray might bring his rook
into the game that's what i'm
territory here yeah
and now if charlie doesn't bring his
knight in i'm gonna flip out
this bishop is pinned now rookie one is
not good and let's fly
now charlie move your knight out don't
take the bishop i mean you could take
the bishop
well i guess come on
instant it should be instant knight f6
or bishop b2 knight f6
i mean he charlie has played a lot of
blitz a lot of it
but this is just not it's not not
sustainable you know it just
he loses the game without giving himself
a chance
i don't get it this is complete
freezing
this is just killing me right now
it's just a developing move
i mean this is crazy
no this is he's not gonna he's not gonna
survive this with a second left
all right it's very hard to watch this
i mean but he needs to take ownership of
this takes and now okay gate pre-move
this
knight f6
yeah he's resigned the game he resigned
the game before
what is this move oh my god this is a
horrible move 94 how do you not develop
your pieces charlie
yeah i mean this is over queen g3 is
also good
because in this position you would have
been able to castle this is
hanging yeah this breaks my heart just
watching this
no but now it's too late because g7
falls
97 queen g7 is just over
saying he's playing i'm out of time to
think of something he's playing like a
700 i mean he's
he hasn't he's capable of so much more
than this rookie five it's over
now reign is good for sure but he's
right rookie five ends the game
but but he is capable of so much better
than this and just we had a lesson he
was finding all the all these tactics
all these ideas
and and and i i don't understand how you
you just basically feel so much out the
window
i didn't even notice now
everybody freaks out and bob jams about
ludwig and stuff but they they're able
to contain themselves somehow
charlie doesn't
no it's over guys it's over it doesn't
matter where you put your queen because
queen b6 there's checking
mate yeah he blunders the he blunders
the queen on top of it
this this might be his worst game this
is his worst game in pog champs
unfortunately
i mean of course rain will see but even
if rain doesn't see a bishop e6 is fine
he's got a bounce back but he doesn't
listen i i try to write him a message
him in the break and stuff oh rain
misses it
what the hell rain okay this is odd
rain saw that he could move his rook but
he doesn't see rookie six
take the queen charlie trade queens come
on you have to what oh my god
oh my god how what is this move
oh my god uh what is wrong with him
he's out of his mind charlie's out of
his mind
oh no
whoops i was so focused on castling
oh whoops how do you miss that
uh oh i mean this is not acceptable
though
you can't let you can't let this happen
yeah i can't [ __ ] believe i did that
yeah rain rain it's definitely
has to see right i mean the way ryan
plays he definitely sees rookie six
oh no uh
yeah i think this is uh where this one
ends yeah
i have to give up a piece here i i
should call him in the break but
that's so [ __ ] disgusting
i did message him this before the
armageddon with ludwig but i think he
disables his messages because
i told him how to play against the c3
sicilian that's so embarrassing
uh
yeah i'm sorry guys this is not how we
wanted it but
let's be let's be positive there's a
second game you can win it if he
can change his his mindset he can win
the second game not if not if it plays
like this i have nothing to do here
grab a pawn i mean i tried to i tried to
stress the psychology this morning
but it's like this you know
at some point you got to realize that
the the sort of the fear
of being confident the fear of faking
until you make it is less
is less less destructive than
the fear of your opponent
yeah but this can't happen in the second
game
no he definitely i mean look let me be
very clear here let me
push this [ __ ] pawn earlier um
i've been in these shoes before where
you resign before the game starts i know
what that looks like i've done that
before and unfortunately charlie
resigned
before the game began and and i'm not
accusing him of doing it consciously
you know but subconsciously i think he
resigned
before this game began and will he be
able
to understand that he actually can win
the second game
before it begins
and this is a good lesson about the
psychology of chess
a lot of groups but i don't contain the
psychology like how you approach the
game
is tied into how you approach
these games against stronger opponents
and stuff
i really hope he he just says there's
nothing to lose i'm going to be
confident
rain might do queen b7 well reigns
i don't know what rain is i've got him
now why is rain repeating moves
okay can you explain to me why rain is
repeating moves
why is rain baby okay okay
against all the odds that was close to a
three-time repetition you can
accidentally repeat like that that was a
two time thank you sentient salad if you
repeat it if you want queen a7 i would
have been a draw
yeah i thought for a second he was about
to repeat but no
oh i'll just [ __ ] i'll go the
distance of course i think rain
i mean i let's be real here i think rain
rains are okay
this is an elementary tactic
um yeah
we i i've never actually i mean this is
interesting i've been on the side of
psychology psychological problems myself
but i've never had like a student
for whom i need to do this and i i don't
want to like we can maybe
we can try to work through this but
no rain's not trolling he can repeat
moves with modern connor
but yeah like in terms of the repetition
i was on
yeah i'm gonna say i'm gonna tell him
call me if you see this message
12k viewers well welcome everybody once
again i i can't sandwich i appreciate
the support guys
and uh let's we believe wow this is
incredible i
i this is the most organic viewers i've
ever had yeah i'll just say some time
here
thanks everybody that was finding time
[ __ ] over the second i lost that
queen by now
hard to watch it let's hope jay richmond
let me let me message charlie and see if
you can give me a call here in the prime
royal
the second i didn't trade the queens i i
immediately lost
me i knew it's the second that happened
all right
i'm gonna tell him i said if you see
this message give me a call i got so
long
because i was afraid of an attack i just
completely forgot
he thinks he automatically is going to
make a mistake and here we go e4
let's let's watch him go after it here
are we prepared for this thank you tcs
261
charlie is going to play bishop c4 i
think i do
um and queen e2 i think i do bishop c4
here's what charlie's going to play
now we're expecting knight f6 from reign
and queen e2 by charlie this is exactly
what we prepared
queen e2 now by charlie come on charlie
queenie two is will be prepared
schmeffy thank you push for this year
one
yep okay so castles and e5
and now now rain has to be careful here
this is a very dangerous line
rain has to know knight c6 which is
pretty crazy i mean
rain has to know to get this other night
out the point is
if you castle charlie will go e5 and ram
this pawn down black's throat
um
hippo sucks thanks for the tier one
appreciate it and rain
realizes that something's up and he
castles an e5 by charlie here
this is exactly what we practiced for
exactly what we practiced for
all right here we go
no no we talked about this quims with
five gifted thank you
oh all right king st
k tank stand for the prime thank you
i'll bite her alone i need to replace my
headphones one sec guys knight back
i still push
and then i develop just a moment guys
okay thank you case hangston
i'm really pumped right now this is
exactly what we talked about
fortunately we didn't have as much time
to talk about black but
he takes okay now charlie takes back
immediately
yep the headphone replacement lex
okay so now the point is if
rain moves his knight back i told
charlie to push the pawnee e6
the thing is because rain took pushing
the pawn e6 might not be
now charlie is in a big position here
white is much better
white is much much better your rain has
to be super super accurate
now this is probably what's gonna happen
now charlie shouldn't push the pawn he
should just develop his knife but
that's what we talked about i just kept
things simple for him
this is looking good rain burning
through his clock now
this is what i like to see
e6 e6 charlie come on e6
this is exactly what we talked about
literally e6
we we had this position on the board
this morning let's push
we have this position on the board and
there we go
there we go now don't worry everything's
under control
f5 knight f3 is what we talked about and
chase the knight away
yeah now refrain takes he loses the
knight oh he lost the knight bishop e6
loses the night we talked about this
yes yes if he takes one come on
reign has to play knight takes up two or
desperado but he loses a piece charlie
is in a position to win this
this was nice prep
all right
rain loses a piece here this is great
this is great strell 1502 thank you the
prime
okay
yeah i was thinking i i i spent an hour
at night thinking well which line should
i recommend him against the perk
i was like this is going to be the line
that causes the most trouble to rain
and uh it has and now charlie needs to
carry this home he needs to he
needs to carry this home and he needs to
slow now he needs to slow down
now rayne can play knight takes f2
charlie
queen f2 and get your night out you're
up a piece you can castle here
bring rook over develop knight and
castle short sorry
but rain taking his time here
this is a great line for white okay
bishop back charlie bring your bishop
back to b3 develop your pieces
i haven't seen that before well rain
played this played this against logic i
didn't
predict anything on my own i just looked
at what he played
and i thought he might repeat it because
you know charlie is usually
uncomfortable with these lines
thank you uh dm's 833. yeah so bishop d5
here is fine bishop b3
um charlie shouldn't over think he's
just bring the bishop back my friend to
these two
b3 is the best now we talked about that
scenario yep good
now knight c6 bishop e3 and what
i'm a little bit concerned about is that
charlie will do this
and then reign will bring his knight
back and charlie will get scared this is
not scary actually
well we prepared it off stream so okay
great
bishop this is the game for charlie to
win
i'm just drinking sparkling water and
coffee i don't even need the coffee
anymore
my hands are shaking all right come on
charlie you got this
technique speed okay c5 doesn't do
anything but should be three attacks the
pawn
i'm worried charlie would go like a3
it's very important here to develop
complete your development knight f3 is
also good
knight f3 is good if he pushes that i
take he takes and i
still up i think i just don't want to
develop this
do i get nervous for all of my students
yes every time my student is playing a
tournament
part of my heart is on the line this
didn't free anything right
okay bishop b3 come on bishop e3 or
knight f3 push
take if he plays knight f3 yeah
definitely on the path to victory i
think that's fine knight f3 or bishop e3
bishop f4 is also
fine but rain can defend his knight with
his other knight that's what i'm a
little worried about
and then rain can bring the knight over
to d4 that is what i'm slightly
concerned about okay rain gets
this knight to c6 that's fine now
charlie needs to bring his night out
i'm a little bit worried that charlie
will go here
mr rovertown thank you but i told him
many times
the ultimate priority is always to bring
her minor pieces in
first knight f3 because rook t1 black
can block with his knight and attack the
queen
this is not a disaster this place right
but i know charlie i know what makes him
uncomfortable
but you gotta get your night out first
charlie
he the fundamentals is what is what what
always
concerns me he saw it
charlie knight f3 come on man the
problem is though knight f3
just develop your pieces
you can take the knight but i don't like
that no need to do that look at this he
plays this
there's literally nothing you need to
overthink a knight f3 and castle
no but he forgets he forgets about his
pieces it's like he forgets about
development
he's looking at rugby one yeah and this
is
the freezing has begun unfortunately
four pieces on this one
i would only have rook
yeah no if this was a casual game you
just bring us
right now i only have knight and he's
saying rook to 1942
okay how do we prevent knight d4 well we
need to cover that square their with our
knife
just play let's just play one place okay
rayne i don't know if he will see knight
before
brain might go here and then charlie's
uh and then charlie's gonna be afraid of
this which you shouldn't be
okay knight e4 is not the end of the
world by the way knights four just move
your queen
white is still winning i don't think
it's that big of a deal
let's yeah queen a5 all right okay now
charlie needs to bring his knight out
here's the thing
you don't need to be afraid of black
winning this fight because then he gives
away his fee and get a bishop he dropped
bishop back to you i'm worried charlie
will go here
knowing charlie he's probably going to
go bishop d2
and uh that is a little bit worrisome
because he pauses his development that
knight d4 is annoying
cheeky weasley thinking for the tier one
but he has to go knight f3 here
no moving his queen that's another one
of his favorites
don't go here though because that's the
same ludwig blunder
do you have any player can make with a
check now he's taking too long here
he was here time advantage is starting
to evaporate
i'd have this beautiful check to win i
mean this is as good as it gets out of
the opening
thank you i died this move wants
now but i told him so many times to not
care about pawns in this position just
develop your damn pieces
just doesn't there's something that that
averse about development
just doesn't want to develop i don't get
it
painting this knight to do what
come in here yeah if he goes knight f3
he'll win this game i think
maybe just break the pitch i mean i know
that it's hard
that exactly mr alamo no but killer
moves way too early he's not developed
yet
he's not developed yet okay goes bishop
d2 what did i tell you guys
what did i tell you he would do um but
that's not a terrible move i'm just i'm
worried that
that he's not developing the long run
now knight d4 is not queen e4
that that is an okay move he doesn't do
anything crazy
that is an okay move
um knight f3 knight d4 is scary yeah
then he'd have to think of moving his
queen that is true what's up gms
15k viewers guys well thanks everybody
um
this is all in good fun of course at the
end of the day we're just enjoying
enjoying the game hopefully rain takes
long too
thank you avery richmond for the prime
okay knight d4 is probably what rain's
gonna play
thank you uh ralph doggy with the prime
appreciate it
okay e6 oh that's that's passing now
knight f3 oh i'm worried charlie will
move his knight though
charlie will definitely look at a
discovered attack instead he should just
move his knight
i'm worried he'll go here which is not
particularly sensible
it's kind of an empty move i think
knight f3 charlie develop pieces
but it didn't change anything for me it
also takes the pressure off of this
i just yeah just develop your pieces
develop knight in castle
knight f3 there we go my man
my men there we go that's where it's at
that is where it's at okay finally
finally gets his night out there you go
and he's up a minute on the clock which
is not a big advantage for him because
he can freeze for like five minutes but
it's better than nothing
i do also have this a6 okay rain is
going to go b5 next
charlie's going to castle
okay b5 by right right is going to play
b5 for sure or
almost which i mean one break and
charlie has to
see the threat of c4 how do you prevent
it well one way of preventing it is to
move the knight away attack the queens
you can't go c4 drop the queen
and if the queen goes back to b6 you go
bishop e3
and you attack that pawn maybe charlie
would probably play a3 here the problem
is that rain can go c4
it's not the end of the world castle i
couldn't i'm worried about charlie going
a3 here with my room um rather than
moving
moving the knight here would be the most
proactive defensive move here because it
would attack though it was actually
knight a4 is
pretty sexy here but um at some point
he's got to have the confidence that
even knight d5 is great queen's in a
pretty [ __ ]
[ __ ] position though 95 would be a great
move here
95 is winning
the clock is okay but it's not very okay
come on charlie you got to move 94.
what if i just evacuated 94 is the best
move here 94.95
when is queen
too long are you long he's taking too
long again right like is that just a bad
idea i'm thinking
you saw it thank you lesson he's
thinking about a move charlie move move
trust yourself come on trust yourself
sure he would [ __ ] see that he's got
to just
do it
he's taking forever to evaluate these
moves anything which sucks
i mean he's so over that's so clear that
he's thinking too highly of
imminent respect rain but he's just he's
thinks that he sees everything oh my god
how
how can you think that what if i just
tried to play here
trust yourself my man 94
take now he's down on the clock now he's
freezing again if i do that though then
i am thrilled i just want to yell at him
right now and move
maybe i was looking at 984 no but but
again he's down to three minutes
does that work 17 000 viewers jesus
come on come on 94 94 just anything
charlie come on
dj barlow's thing with the tier one
wow it's crazy yeah
this is just no no no no no no no don't
take just queen takes
i'm taking too much time i'm going to
try and it goes nighty for me let's just
be real
finding this move is crazy this is
hanging he finds
94 which is ridiculous but he takes too
long doing it
thank you jackie no legs this guy is a
freaking hero
knight a4 is an insane move to find
though
so that is an amazing move he's
attacking the queen
bringing the knight to the side and he's
going to take
hopefully rain takes a long time too
that works i'm down on time anyway
okay b4 is good now rain rain knows what
he's doing now now there's no threat of
c4 so bishop b3 is good here
bishop e3 is the best move piling on the
pawn
piling on the pawn i mean the problem
with with charlie is he he thinks about
his past
like oh how long did i take come on
bishop e3 charlie move move
move
queen c4 is fine
yeah he's contemplating the meaning of
life right now with three minutes on the
clock come on
bishop e3 immediately
oh my god i can't play this one i'm on
bishop v3 yeah you can because if i take
he takes
he's playing perfectly right now oh wait
no but but three minutes now this is
what's gonna kill him
it's crazy how his worst enemy is
himself
this is unbelievable that he does this
to himself when he sees
watch [ __ ] time again
there's no words for this this is
unbelievable
should be three completely winning
position bishop e3 move
he's hovering and hovering and hovering
just what's the worst that could happen
jesus absolutely be [ __ ] i just can't
see it
i just can't [ __ ] see where oh my god
the the lack of confidence even for
somebody but i mean
now he's literally this is unbelievable
under two minutes now
there we go he plays it though i mean
he's playing amazing
chess amazing chess he is playing
amazing chess but he is doing it just
too slowly he doesn't realize
the clock is as big a part of the game
as the position is
now he's down to two minutes now he can
do this he can play with two minutes
he's played bullet
and and the way he's playing this he's
playing like a grandmaster playing good
freaking grandmaster or three three
hundred thank you probably
this is the right move but the problem
is that he analyzes it and
analyzes it and he's good enough now to
trust his instincts
but i am all right i took
yeah i wish there was a little bit more
time i took but you can do i believe in
him
he beat ludwig with like a minute on the
clock in a complicated position
take the knight take the pawn come on
charlie immediately this is winning on
the spot
take take expose the attack on the
bishop come on come on take it quickly
quickly take it
take the pawn take the knight and take
the pawn it's so straightforward
he's up a piece and he can be up a
second piece
i just have to play there we go he takes
c5 it's perfectly good enough that's
good enough that is definitely good
enough she doesn't take takes and takes
both rooks under attack
this is completely winning will he carry
this home
but i i think you see we dr for the
prime look at this play 95 that's a
second piece come on
charlie that's a free piece that is a
free piece and he takes it immediately
there you go
perfect this is amazing amazing level of
play
all right this is winning now he's just
got to play fast
simplify celebrate with a prime thank
you knight f7 is a threat here i don't
think he's going to see that though
take the rook and rook the 8 check is
crushing charlie take the rook
take the rook clay freeman tier one
thank you there we go
rook d8 check is is simple and crushing
evacuate
this is devastation where's the most
active square for the knight d7 is fine
here too
simplifying can't do that he just takes
with them come on move
rook d8 or queen f3 he's got to do it
fast though
do it now do it now knight f7 is even
better
if he sees this that that'll be crazy
knight d7 find it
that's a simplifying move it's not the
best but it simplifies it simplifies the
position and i like that
he has to pre-move rook takes d7
he's playing guys he's playing right now
i cannot stress how phenomenally he is
playing right now oh i could have just
taken i couldn't
write about the time the wrong way i'm
beyond proud of how far he's complaining
oh my god
i'm just worried that he's gonna lose on
time he just went right in he's playing
like a 2200 now 97 was a little bit
timid oh no
i wish he would have taken oh [ __ ]
god
but the man is we have mulligans in this
tournament
thank you just for the tour and
appreciate it look he moved brilliantly
i could have just went straight this way
but it's fine
oh no it would not have ended
okay take the take the night and go
queen after three trade questions oh
jeepers
i was panicking about missing the what
are the odds that i get away with this
if i play five back or 98 enough to take
it
yeah you gotta refocus i mean this is
like rookie mistakes queen f3 because
this is
amazing now
now he's taking forever panicking 95
back back
go back that's fine too oh my god right
here
it's crazy i need him to stay here
actually
what is he doing night see if i know
it's not me but he
gives the night away like that how do i
get him to stay there okay take it
something dude you're coming over here
for a check
god he takes it he's killing himself
here with the clock i'm running low on
time
what no no what is this oh my god what
oh i just gave him i don't know now he's
oh
he's still much better he's up in the
free queen
he just gets in his own head like like
it's unbelievable how he gets his own
double stack rooks or d6 f4 stopping
stopping 95. i like that man there's
increment
but now rain now rain's gonna go nicely
raining
he needs to give him some more credit
how do you play knight f6 it's just
unbelievable
yeah queen b5 is an amazing move a4 he's
going to take on poisson
and then and then he's going to go
knight c5 and oh it's not looking great
okay oh rain the knight take charlie
take it take the knight charlie
take the knife yes all right
still winning still up a rook
okay bishop e6 is the simplest here will
he see it well i thought i could go all
the way up there
queen e6 bishop e6 anything rook d1 just
charlie move come on move please move
make a move
oh my god g4 is fine but it's weak and
in queen c5 and then you might blunder a
fork
ah queen c5 and a blunder a fork but
then queen f3
queen f2 we have to cover the queen
charlie cover with the queen ah
queen c6 queen g2 queen g2
or queen f3 queen g2 or queen f3 and
oops
come on come on see it please see it
wait what's going on oh no
what is this move wow this is like
complete meltdown by charlie complete
total meltdown it's just he's straight i
don't understand this over chuck
now he's gonna lose on time make a move
queen f3 move the queen he's still fine
yeah well it's not meant to be sometimes
thank you dan fave move the king why is
it taking three seconds there we go
dan fey 22 thank you for the prime
okay so maybe rain will blunder who
knows
f5 take the pawn charlie take the punk
queen d5 it's still a game
it's still a game charlie there we go
wait a second we believe
we believe we believe
gonna go here though
wait a minute this is not losing yet
it's equal material now charlie's king
is weak so is rings
f5 charlie f5 come on attack police
attack please move
attack f5 f5 i mean
he's a hero for for finding some of
these moves but the the meltdown is just
oh amazing okay now he's attacking he's
got 12 seconds
if reign takes charlie needs to take
with the queen he needs to see the
background i'm so
[ __ ] sad i had the game we'll have to
do a drill
where we do nothing but what we did
remember that lesson we did where i gave
him
20 seconds to meet me we're gonna do
this for 24
goddamn hours that's what we're gonna do
oh my god this is winning
if rain takes he gets mated but maybe
rain is this
oh my god rook f7 charlie oh wait a
minute this is unclear
now i this might not be winning for
white king h6 by reign
queen f4 queen f4 don't give this
charlie's gonna give this check isn't he
queen f4 back back back h4 no he missed
made in one
oh man but that's a great move but queen
h3 is made
when rey misses it too
oh god rain can queen g one though this
is bad
this is bad don't don't block it don't
block it move your king charlie
ah oh boy
we're gonna have to trade i think
king h do only move
only move charlie only move only move
there we go
okay wait a second yeah the problem is
that rain can force the drone don't go
up go down
don't go up charlie don't go up go down
go down go down
okay yes ah ryan taking the pawns
get away from there get away from the
charlie don't go into the corner
get away from there yes good rank and
one or his queen here maybe reign one or
his queen
i hope rain maybe gives this check no
thingy too
not over yet charlie just gotta run run
away from there
don't go king g1 king youtube is good i
can't even think about the best place to
put my [ __ ] king
this is a disaster
all right it's not looking good guys
this is not looking good because the
problem is the draw wins the match for
right
exactly raw winston reigns second i
played my night i saw it too
the [ __ ] sound as robert says this is
anyone's game rain below a minute here
rain below a minute guys rain might lose
on time if he if he takes a long time
here he might lose on time
okay king king up get the hell out of it
get get your king up charlie get your
king up
yeah the problem with this move bishop
f7 here bishop f7
no it's a draw and charlie just he
doesn't find the stuff in time pressure
he sort of
he just melts down a little bit yeah
king f3 charlie
look at this defense though stopping the
pun
man charlie is a hero for some of these
moves i just need to hold
the line like he is the play has been a
phenomenal
just the confidence that's the only
thing stopping him from like greatness
and chess
uh charlie just needs to move his bishop
around the diagonal do nothing here just
move your bishop to g4 and stuff
it's a drop it's a dead draw if charlie
can just move
what you don't want to do is move your
king and allow the pawn forward yeah
it's a draw bishop d7 bishop d2
yeah it's a draw and he's gonna hold his
head up high here
it is a draw
he can't deliver a check and he can't
push this and he can't take this
i know charlie started so wait wait what
is rain doing why is he giving the pawn
up
okay wait a second wait a second thank
you whistle cube
no more charlie can get his king up and
here's what he can do
hold the little team dandy three okay no
no charlie get your king down get your
king to eat two please
okay get your k get your king here oh
boy oh
rain rain is going to go for the win
here charlie's got to get his king king
up
king e2 oh no b3 now get your king down
okay king up is fine but king d4 and
then he's got to defend
b5 king c4 and king b5 wait a second
oh king b5 charlie please see it charlie
you have to see king b5
charlie you have to see this move you
have to see this move
charlie what is there to look at
how are you missing me come on can't be
fire charlie please
what is this he thought did he think was
made or something
oh no he's gonna but it doesn't matter i
mean the thing is even if it's a draw
then
it is literally the only move yeah
it's fine he's not lost it's still a
drop it is still a drawn game bishop a4
charlie bishop a4
but but he's got to defend this pawn
okay king d3 is fine
it is a draw um still but the problem i
was still holding
a win or something how about a draw okay
draw offer by
charlie rayne should just take it no
just take it it wins the match for him
and it is a draw drawn position
but of course so i was still harboring
some hopes that uh perhaps
bishop blunder might happen i mean i
can't no matter what happens i can't
bishop c6 charlie's got to move his
bishop now
bishop c6 come on now what he doesn't
want to do is move the bishop away from
this diagonal
but i can do this now bishop c6 bishop
c6 charlie come on bishop a4 is fine
because now he'll probably go king eight
three and then he's gonna show bb i
guess
this sucks okay i hate this
yeah rain offers a draw and charlie
takes it
and uh this is a drop this is uh
objectively a drawing position because
black cannot make
i can't believe i missed that ryan is i
didn't notice that the queen really
bottom line is that black can't move the
king away from a3 because bishop takes i
had such a crushing move yeah
and that is definitely true but
definitely there is a light
in the tunnel we know immediately
quit after this [ __ ] prodigy plays
the night
it was watching matching
it's not and the thing is not that you
didn't play well it's
purely a non-chess issue it is purely a
confidence issue
purely a confidence bishop to block
because wasn't the best decision he
would
and that is a good thing not a bad right
so
the guy he has potential
oh you have to work very in a very
substantive way honestly
bishop was pinned what are your like
immediate reflections how do you feel
going forward and just in general uh
pretty good
i was wondering though in a couple of
things during the game
we can take a look yeah let's hop in an
analysis board i was wondering
where to play after dr like was dropping
the bishop back
after winning that uh the right call or
should i yeah
so so let's look at it concretely let me
invite you
thanks for 100 bits all right there we
go
okay so this was perfect
um dropping the bishop back was great
and
if you think about it there are certain
moves there are certain positions when
there are alternatives and the way you
got to think about things
isn't i got to find the move but rather
for the time for the next
freaking couple of years that's what i
have to worry about is like marginal
differences you've got to find a decent
move and your instincts are good enough
where you're usually going to
immediately fall on
a decent momentum b3 is fine bishop f4
is fine
the only small thing here would be i
would say knight f3
uh would be the most natural move
focusing on developing your minor pieces
um and you know i felt like you were you
started hesitating here a little bit
uh did you consider getting your night
out uh so here i think i just tried to
remember what we were doing
not re like so i don't know if you saw
my stream but i figured he was playing
d4
next uh yeah i was trying to figure out
like some scheme to take that away
and i spent a lot of time on that and
couldn't figure it out so then i just
defaulted to what we went over which was
d1
right but obviously the position shifted
because you're now up a piece knight f3
would be that way because here
what do you do like what is the simplest
move oh just take it
up and i think in your mind sometimes
you're afraid of not to put words in
your mouth but like
him attacking your pieces but
a threat in and of itself is not a scary
thing where can you shift your knight
so it remains centralized uh
i mean i could even push it up to d5 but
it'll just push upon but
yeah so i would go e4 okay and then
castle and this
focus on the fundamentals has to be
obsessive like have i completed my
development
because when you play in accordance with
the fundamentals
um you're not playing magnus carlsen
you're playing opponents who
you know are going this is just
automatically going to give you an edge
so rook d1
now bishop d2 was fine you could have
again played knight f3
and this might have been something you
were worried about i assume
yeah but it's not something that you
should worry we talked about
the importance of sometimes giving away
a couple of ponds when you're up a piece
what do you gain in return for the pawn
positionally why is this a good
trade-off for white
like conceptually um has to move his
queen
and then i get to castle right and also
notice
that his fiance bishop is gone okay and
we talked about that scenario right when
a fiance bishop is gone
there are dark square weaknesses around
his king you kind of notice that
intuitively right
and you have two bishops they're both
aimed at his king
in the long run black is busted here you
could even
you could even refrain from castling and
execute a plan that we talked about
in terms of attacking his king that's
what i said during the stream too i
regretted castling because i could have
just pushed that h pawn
right but you shouldn't have discastling
is i was actually very happy that you
castled
really instead of just pushing because
you played like a good russian school
boy there's different ways of
approaching every position and
for me it's much more important that you
master the fundamentals then you make
you know then you find some like
slightly more accurate move at some
point and knight a4 was a freaking
this was this is a grand master move
because i mentioned it initially i was
like there's no way he finds it
and i'm you know i'm the first person to
put faith in you but like this was
amazing knight to the side going after
the c
pawn and i was really happy that you
didn't just play a3
which would have allowed him to bury
your bishop on a2
but obviously at this point you were
starting to spend a lot of time the
other movie wanted to play would have
also been very good
94. okay and
sometimes i wish that you found the
middle ground 30 45 seconds is fine
but you get in these zones where i think
what this comes from is you think that
well my opponent would have for sure
seen this move so there's no way it's
good he definitely prepared something
against it
and i think that's definitely something
that i was uh thinking during this game
so i wasn't making like the best or
like like solid moves thinking that it
was already just going to be wrong
against them so maybe that's just
another problem and the nature of chess
improvement is that you
start seeing [ __ ] that earlier uh
you wouldn't have seen that's why that's
how you become better than people your
own rating that's how you get rise to
the next level
because you start effortlessly seeing
moves that your opponents of the same
rating are not seeing
and you start and the moment you flip
that switch
and i'm not saying recklessly play moves
immediately you know you still have to
always blunt or check as do i as does
anybody
because the moment you let your guard
down there you start blundering
um but the moment you flip that switch
you will realize that
you know it's not that they've seen
something they've prepared something
that'll be true one time out of 50. most
of the time
you're just seeing and understanding the
position a lot better than bonus of the
same rating so 94
if he drops the screen back to b6 can
you find a way to put more pressure on
this pawn
yeah i just bring up my bishop right put
it on e3 bingo i guarantee you
with full due respect terrain is a good
player he didn't see
this idea like he didn't sense the fact
that you could just pile up on his pawn
and um that would have been good the 94
was phenomenal bishop e3 amazing move
attacking the pawn also could have
played it quickly
and of course this was the moment when i
started blowing a gasket
so here you have a couple of options now
you saw rook t8 immediately after you
played your move
yeah and is it fair to say that that
impacted the course of the game you you
could
100 yeah yeah i didn't even realize he
could block with the bishop i thought he
was going to have to block with the
queen
for i was still in my own head thinking
that bishop was pinned from last game
so it didn't even occur to me okay but
knight d7 is
you're still up a freaking rook and
the reality is and i i don't know how to
say i don't want to like kind of say
like oh i've been through like this and
that
but i've had experiences where
i've so i think you know to become a gm
you need like three grandmaster norms
like you need three
tournament performances at a certain
level nine tournaments were because of a
single move that i didn't make
that i immediately recognized afterwards
i failed to get a grandmaster not i
could have made a single move
differently which i saw
didn't trust myself lost the game lost
my opportunity to become a gm
and this took another year to recover
from that that's happened several times
in my career where like
it's either that or there was a
tournament i played in vegas
it was called the millionaire chess
highest price fund of any tournament
ever hundred thousand dollars
missed um and top four players
of the open tournament qualified into
the bracket to
compete for like the lowest prize of 20k
last round game
if i win it i um i get into the bracket
i missed the win
and then i lost the playoffs so like
these things just happen
and um you have to focus on immediately
putting the move behind you what's
the move that's made is made and chess
is brutal for that reason now in
addition to rook d
you have another tactic here that wins
the game do you notice the pressure that
you're putting on these puns
yeah and you notice that um
you've got all these attackers so you
need to start looking for sacrifices
what sacrifice can you find
night sack on f7 and if gang takes
i just push queen take e6 right but the
reality is you're gonna make a
[ __ ] gazillion more mistakes like
this and here
what would be the simplest most
uncreative unoriginal move ever
just take his knife take the damn night
and now continue playing in the most
freaking by the bookway ever
uh stack the rooks stack the rooks
perfect and you don't give a damn about
this pawn
because you're gonna get your rook try
to get your d and if you don't get it to
d8 to trade rooks where else can you put
the stroke
a second rank yeah d7 and then queen f3
to pile up on the queen and trade queens
so you're seeing this stuff effortlessly
of course you didn't take your rug that
was very i think you just did that to be
nice yeah
maybe yeah and and here you have a
knockout blow
because what do you have to see you have
to make these observations instantly
your pinning is pawn can you exploit
that
yeah i can just bring that bishop into
e6 van gogh or even queen takes c6
use the weaponize the queen trade when
you're up a rook
queen trades are equivalent to
resignation for him right
so you use the queen tray to force him
into like something like this
but now you're going to take the
spawning question and
and here was the last moment where you
had a win
what was it and i totally get that at
this point it's so easy to panic but
now i want you to find it
uh queen g2 and if he takes a rook
i take his rook right it's crazy how
like after the fact
you know everything becomes so clear
yeah but in the game it's it's like
you're
you're losing your [ __ ] of course which
is which is always going to be the case
to some degree and
you still played really well
unfortunately he took with the right
pawn
if he took i was really hoping he would
take with the other pawn and allow you
to take the rook and check made him
yeah it would have been so nice yeah now
here you had a
like a five-fed move because like how
would i think about this
taking on f7 is supernatural but he has
this h6 square for his king could you
take that square away
initially pushing that pawn yeah and it
would have forced him into an only move
because if he brings his queen back to
defend the pawn what do you do break the
bishop
you're on fire yep and otherwise he's
got to find this move king back
so that this move doesn't happen with
check but
you know maybe he would have found it
you took here and uh here he had a
checkmate actually
but it's nice but
i was surprised he didn't take the draw
like i was surprised he didn't repeat
moves
and and yeah this was a drop at the end
now you could have drawn in an easier
way like here for example king b5
defend the pawn and then just go back
and forth with my bishop
and just go back and forth like
literally do nothing everything is well
actually here you can take the pawn but
that's
it's a risky move although it still
draws what does it allow
it allows him to uh
contr he can push that pawn with check
and take my pawn
and how do you draw
i just have to take that well no like
yeah oh i do bishop against king as a
drop
just go here and give you know what he
would have taken
goodbye yeah so that is the drawing even
at the end it's a draw
because black cannot make progress you
just you shift your bishop along this
thing the only thing black can do is go
a4
and you literally do nothing or bishop
e8 so
if the king ever moves you do what
the moment the king moves to pizza oh i
just take take
one now it's the only way to make
progress to go here no
this is like pretty straightforward now
if the king takes on b3 what's the
easiest draw
just take that pawn behind him and if a
takes v3
this is called as alexander to get
opposite-colored bishops
this is a draw because you will keep the
bishop on this diagonal
and there's no way that he can possibly
contest that bishop he can only bring
his king in and promote but then you
take the pawn and it's bishop against
gank
so oftentimes in opposite-colored bishop
end games you can be up
two even three pawns but because
you have dibs on the light squares you
can often set up a blockade if that
makes sense conceptually
okay that makes sense so but other than
that i mean phenomenal opening here
um and i think with some confidence
and with some improvement in your
ability to convert positions
within with a little time left uh
you know the sky is the limit i uh you
know i know this is a
painful moment so i'm not gonna run off
of the mouth but
you know this this tournament has been a
pleasure and i think you've
if we look at your games when you first
started like seven eight months ago
um i actually did that a couple days ago
it's really shocking to see
some of the ideas that we're talking
about now versus some of the [ __ ] we
talked about then
so yeah you have my admiration for that
thank you it feels a lot better it's
just gotta make sure not to uh
make careless dumb [ __ ] moves
thinking uh overthinking things yeah and
i mean the other thing is
you're always because the types of
openings you play you're always going to
encounter
bad [ __ ] crazy moves right you're gonna
people are gonna do weird
stuff against you and if you have
command of the fundamentals the reason
you even learn
principles is to give you a
a you know gps system for dealing with
weird moves and at some point you become
confident that your ability
to respond to them defeats your
opponent's preparation whatever people
look up
because up to like 2 000 level nobody
really invests
crazy amounts of time in the opening so
people have their own little systems
but if you have knowledge of how to
respond in those general scenarios
you run circles over them essentially
yeah i feel like
i'm pretty strong in the open compared
to the people i play in the pool which
is nice
and you'll you'll keep getting better
you know we can keep looking at the area
and obviously i'll
i will let you relax from chess for as
long as you need i mean i
appreciate all the sessions we have and
and all the time
that we get to spend really even though
i'm losing my losing my [ __ ] on stream
but
let that not obscure the fact that i'm i
am very appreciative of
all the work that you put in and all the
progress you made man
it's fun i agree so
yeah i'll let you i'll let you you
you've earned
earned yourself some rest and maybe a
large stake
or or whatever but um you know
pog champs for uh you're definitely
gonna kick some ass
and um i'm always here to help you keep
getting better